SO IN A YEAR WHEN HALF OF US
FORGOT TO UNMUTE OURSELVES,
WE WERE ALL REMINDED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF SOUND.
BUT WE STILL ONLY TALK ABOUT
WATCHING A MOVIE.
WE TELL PEOPLE TO GO AND SEE
A MOVIE, BUT THE BEST FILMS ARE
THE ONES WE FEEL, RIGHT HERE.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING TAUGHT
AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE FOR MY
ROLE IN "SOUND OF METAL," AND
WHAT I LEARNED FROM JEREMY,
MY SIGN INSTRUCTOR, WAS THAT
TRUE LISTENING AND
TRUE COMMUNICATION GOES FAR
BEYOND WHAT WE HEAR WITH OUR EARS
IT'S SOMETHING WE DO
WITH OUR ENTIRE BODIES.
THE FILMS NOMINATED TONIGHT
FOR BEST SOUND UNDERSTOOD THIS.
THEY MOVED US BEYOND
THEIR SOUNDSCAPES.
THEY SOARED,
EVEN IN THEIR SILENCES.
AND THEY STRUCK US AT OUR CORE.
HERE ARE THE NOMINEES FOR
ACHIEVEMENT IN SOUND.
“GREYHOUND,” WARREN SHAW,
MICHAEL MINKLER, BEAU BORDERS,
AND DAVID WYMAN.
“MANK,” REN KLYCE,
JEREMY MOLOD,
DAVID PARKER, NATHAN NANCE,
AND DREW KUNIN.
“NEWS OF THE WORLD,” OLIVER
TARNEY, MIKE PRESTWOOD SMITH,
WILLIAM MILLER,
AND JOHN PRITCHETT.
“SOUL,” REN KLYCE, COYA ELLIOTT,
AND DAVID PARKER.
“SOUND OF METAL,”
NICOLAS BECKER, JAIME BAKSHT,
MICHELLEE COUTTOLENC,
CARLOS CORTES, AND PHILLIP BLADH.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO --
“SOUND OF METAL”
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
MICHELLEE COUTTOLENC,
CARLOS CORTES, AND PHILLIP BLADH.
SO, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
ACADEMY, FOR RECOGNIZING THIS
0:02:08.760,1193:02:47.295
NICOLAS BECKER, JAIME BAKSHT,
WONDERFUL FILM.
I'M SORRY, MY ENGLISH IS NOT
VERY GOOD. SO I'M
GOING TO READ A BIT
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT
TO MAKE PROBLEMS.
SO THANK YOU, DARIUS AND ABE, FOR
RECOGNIZING THIS WONDERFUL FILM.
NO, THANK YOU, DARIUS AND ABE, THE
TRUE MASTER BEHIND “SOUND OF METAL.”
THANK YOU SACHA AND BERT
FOR YOUR GREAT SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RIZ, PAUL AND OLIVIA
FOR YOUR AMAZING PERFORMANCES
TO MIKKEL FOR HIS COLLABORATION,
TO PHILLIP AND JEREMY
FOR THEIR COMMITMENTS,
TO HEIKKI, KARI, PIETU
ON THEIR CREATIVITY
TO CAROLINA,
FOR HER BRILLIANCE
TO JAIME, MICHELLEE AND CARLOS,
TOP OF THE NOTCH.
ON BEHALF OF PHILLIP, JAIME
MICHELLEE, CARLOS AND I,
I THANK YOU ERIC, MICHEL, ROSEANNE,
ROSALINDA, SABINA, DAVID, PABLO, VICTORIA,
CESAR, CHRIS, FANNIE, MARTA, ORLANDO,
BRUNO, CARLA, CONSTANCE, ANTON AND IAN.
WE ARE FIVE ON THE TEAM.
THAT'S WHY IT'S A BIT LONG.
SO, NOW I WOULD LIKE TO SAY
SOMETHING MORE PERSONAL.
FELLINI ONCE SAID, IN THE
HISTORY OF CINEMA,
BEYOND THE EVOLUTION
OF STYLES AND TECHNIQUES
WHAT STAYS EMBODIED IN FILMS
IS THEIR HUMAN VITALITY.
AND WHOEVER ENJOYS IT RECEIVES A
CHARGE OF ENERGY, SOMETHING PULSING
MYSTERIOUS AND VIBRANT.
"SOUND OF METAL" RECEIVED FROM
ITS TEAM SO MUCH CARE,
LOVE, AND ATTENTION.
SO MUCH ENERGY THAT WE BELIEVE
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
THE FILM HAS BEEN RECEIVED
BY THE AUDIENCE SO BEAUTIFULLY.
SO, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.